All right, class. Welcome
back. This is Howard. Uh,
last two weeks we're going
to have a slightly different
schedule for the problem
sets.
I'm going to assign something today,
which is due next Wednesday,
giving you enough times so
you can plan your moves.
Then I will probably give you one last
problem set with two or three problems on
whatever I do near the end.
We'll have to play it by year.
Okay,
so this is another new
topic on thermodynamics,
a fresh beginning for those who want a
fresh beginning and her songs and stuff
you probably have seen in high school,
some of it at least.
So the whole next four lectures are
devoted to the study of heat temperature,
the heat transfer,
things like that.
So we are going to start
with the intuitive definition
of temperature everybody
has. So hang on to that. That's
the right, the right intuition.
But as physicists, of course we want
to be more precise, more careful.
So let's say you have the
notion of hot and cold.
Even that requires a little more,
uh,
precision that introduces the notion
of what is called thermodynamic
equilibrium.
Just like mechanical equilibrium.
This is a very important concept,
so I'll tell you what equilibrium
is with a concrete example.
If you take a cup of hot water,
then you'd take another cup of cold water.
Each cup,
if you wait a sufficiently long,
is set to be in a state of equilibrium.
As long as the cups were isolated from
the outside world and not allowed to cool
down or heat up, we think they
maintain a certain temperature.
We say it's in a state of
thermal equilibrium because
this temperature does not
seem to change. Now we have not
defined what temperature is precisely,
but we can talk about whether whatever
it is has changed or not chains,
so it will send me down
to some temperature. It'll
maintain the temperature.
Be Very careful. If you'd leave
a cup of coffee in this room,
it will cool down because the room
has got a different temperature.
What I'm talking about, a cup of coffee
that's been isolated from everything.
It maintains the temperature.
Here's another cup of cold drink with
at what we feel is a lower temperature.
You had both in a state of equilibrium.
Equilibrium is when
the macroscopic properties for the system,
I've stopped changing.
If you don't pour one of
cups into the other one,
that's going to be a period when the
system is not in equilibrium in the sense
that it doesn't have a well
defined temperature. For example,
if you just bought it from the top,
the hot stuff is at the top
of cold stuff in the bottom.
That's a period of transition when
you really cannot even say what the
temperature of the mixture is.
Some parts of some parts are called
that system doesn't have a temperature.
What'd you wait long enough till the
two parts of gotten to know each other?
They will turn into some undrinkable mass,
but nice thing is it'll have
a well defined temperature.
That's again a system in equilibrium,
so you've got to understand
that temperature and thermal
equilibrium represent
gross macroscopic properties
and that aren't always defined
at the microscopic level.
It's no secret.
We all know that everything is
made of atoms and molecules.
The atoms and molecules that form the
liquid or the gas always have well defined
states. Each molecule has a
certain location, certain velocity,
but at a macroscopic level,
when you don't look into the fine details,
focus on a few things like temperature.
They don't always have a well defined
value. That's what you got to understand.
Things have a well defined value
when they have settled down,
how long does it take to settle down?
That's a matter of what
system you're studying,
but generally you can all tell when it
has settled down. Here's another example.
Suppose you take a gas and you'll put
it inside this piston here with some gas
inside you've put some weights
and everything is in equilibrium.
You say this in equilibrium because the
macroscopic things things so you can see
with your naked eye, nothing is
changing. It's going to just sit there,
but if you suddenly now remove,
say a third of the weights,
the Piston is going to rise up,
shake it on a little bit,
maybe settled down in the new location.
If you wait a few seconds,
then the new location will act again,
settled down and you won't see anything
with the naked eye that looks like
anything has happened in between UNC,
the piston moving, the gas is turbulent,
the pressure is high in some region, low
in some regions than it's set in stone.
This is the notion of systems are in
equilibrium and in between the states of
the system which are not in equilibrium.
No benefits system is in equilibrium.
We can assign to the
temperature that we call t,
right? No, we don't know
anything about this temperatures,
so we're going to build
it up from scratch.
Other than your instinctive
feeling for what temperature is.
Yeah.
One of the laws of thermodynamics
called the zero plot. Is it a club?
Because they wrote down the first law.
Then they went back and had an idea of
what is even more profound and they said,
we'll call it zero o'clock zero law says
if a and B at the same temperature and
B and c at the same temperature
than Amc at at the same temperature.
I see this belief in the audience thing.
Why do you call this a lot?
Look,
I think that is the key to would being
able to speak about temperature globally
is the assumption that if I take a
thermometer and measure something there,
then they come back and the thermometer
here and it reads the same number than I
may conclude these two entities which
never met each other directly but also at
the same temperature. That's not, uh,
that seems pretty obvious to you.
But that is the whole notion
of temperature is predicated
on the fact that you
can define an attribute called temperature
that can be globally compare between
two systems that never met
directly but met a third system.
Okay.
So once we hate,
once we have some idea of hot and cold,
let us decide now to be more
quantitative. It's like saying, you know,
somebody stall in shot is not enough.
We go into how tall, how many feet,
how many inches, how many millimeters.
So we want to get quantitative.
All we have right now is
notion of hot and cold.
So what we tried to do is to find some
way to be more precise about how hard and
how cold.
So what people said is,
uh, let's look at some things in the world
that seemed to depend on temperature.
One thing that seems to depend
on temperature is the following.
You take this meter stick in the
National Bureau of standards,
kept them some glass
case at some temperature.
You pull it out or make a duplicate of it.
You pull it outside and leave it in
the room. What you may find this,
if the room was hotter
than the glass case,
this rod then expense to a new length.
So one route is outside the case,
one rod is inside the case.
So the comparison is meaningful.
Nothing has been done to this guy
in the air condition glass case,
but this one is expanding.
So one way to define temperature is
to simply ask how long is this rod?
And somehow correlate the length of the
rod with temperature by some fashion.
So you can do that.
So what do you need to do that?
What you need to do first is to define,
put some markings on it so that for
each extra, something that grows,
we can say the temperature has gone up
by some amount so that we need units for
temperature.
That's completely arbitrary.
And do you need some standards? Just
like this meter stick, you know,
it's not nothing intrinsic in nature. The
water meter, we just made it up and say,
let's call that a meter. In the
case of the meter, the zero applies.
If you bring a meter stick
next to mine and we agree,
you can take the meter stick somewhere
else and define that to be the meter.
Because if the stickers, as long as
that one and as long as that one,
then those two are equal in length.
But temperature,
you similarly going to use this rod and
say if this rod as a certain length when
then when it kept on top of this bucket
of some fluid and at the same length
when I keep it on that bucket,
then the two buckets that
are at the same temperature.
So we can use markings on this ride
compared to the unexpanded length as a
measure of temperature.
So what people do is to pick something
a little easier than this, right?
They notice the liquids expand when
you heat them. That's why you know,
summer day if you fill your gas tank,
you have to leave some room at the top
to the overflow can come out at the top
are, you shouldn't fill it completely,
otherwise it'll bust the tech.
So liquids expand. So one way to measure
temperature, maybe fix some liquid,
put it there
and then
put it on hot rooms and maybe watch
the liquid expand to the new height.
Yeah.
And then just try some markings and each
marking can be a certain temperature,
but people had a better
idea than this one.
They add the following idea of thermometer
where you have a lot of fluid in the
reservoir,
a very thin tube evacuated at the
top and the fluid then is here.
So what's clever about this is that
if this expanse but 1% you right,
you should be good enough to
see 1% increase in height.
If this fluid expense by 1% in volume,
that one person in volume and it planes
sub this narrow tube can claim to quite
a bit.
The extra volume you get by expansion
will be the area of this tube flames,
the extra delta x way with that expense.
So you had a magnifying the expansion by
making all the expander fluid claim of
this extremely narrow too. In
fact, the tube is so narrow,
you cannot probably even see it well,
which is why they're a little
prison that magnifies the,
the Medicare your alcohol
in a thermometer. Okay,
so we have some way of
following temperature.
Now we can draw some lines,
arbitrary lines. It doesn't
matter. That can be zero.
That can be filed, that can be 19 you
just got to make sure there's monotonic.
Then whenever it's on 21 we may
argue that 21 is no harder than 90
what do you want a better scale than that?
Even though that's mathematically adequate
and practice what people decide yes
to do it as follows.
They said we want to set up thermometer
so that people all over the world in
different parts of the world, different
countries, different labs can all agree.
So we will make it possible for
everyone to make their own thermometer.
By the following recipe,
we will dip this guy in a bucket
which has got some ice and some water
that's called the melting point of water.
So that uh,
are the freezing point of water up melting
point of ice or the freezing point of
water.
It doesn't matter.
We notice that as water cools down
in the world around the suddenly ice,
he was big into farm.
We go to the temperature at which that
happens for the first time and we dipped
the thermometer there and
whatever reading they get,
we will postulate to be
zero degrees centigrade.
That is just a definition.
We believe that's a good definition
because people all over the world can do
that. Of course, if you live in Kuwait,
that's not going to work for you.
There no ice,
but they've figured out when the
parts of the world where you had ice,
this is a very good definition.
You get ice, you got zero degrees.
Then they said, let's find another
universally accessible thing,
which as you all know is
the boiling point of water.
If you put water on the stove,
it heats up and he'd up and heats up and
suddenly it begins to bubble and boil
and evaporate.
That temperature is going to
be called a hundred degrees,
hundred degrees centigrade.
Then
you take this call in between zero and
a hundred and you divided into 100 equal
parts
and that is postulated to
be the temperature anywhere
between zero and a hundred
if you've gone 79% of the way
to the top from here to here,
the temperature is 79 degrees
because that's how the
Dignitas and introducing that
to some degree of scale and
you guys know that are different scales.
You can have the fat in height scale,
you can have any other skill in which
what you want to call the freezing point
is different.
Somebody thinks a zero,
somebody thinks it's 32 and you can again
call this something else and you can
divide this interval in 200 parts,
180 parts of whatever you like,
but the philosophy is the same.
You have to find two points which are
reproducible conveniently and divide the
region between them into
some number of equal steps.
If it's a hundred equals steps,
you say it's a centigrade scale
provided the lowest one is called zero.
The sow, you have thermometers. Now,
there are some problems with this one
problem is that the boiling point of water
does not seem to be very reliable
because if you boil water
on in Aspen for example,
you know it doesn't seem to boil.
It seems to boil more
readily than in the plains.
You can ask how do you know that maybe
it is still doing the same thing.
I know that because I try to cook
something, Cook some rice or vegetables,
I find they don't cook at all.
Then where it boils before it cooks.
That way we know it's probably boiling
earlier in the mountains then in the
plains,
so who's going to decide what the real
temperature is so you have to be more
careful when you say a boiling point
and freezing point because things don't
boil. The don't seem to boil at a certain
predictable and fixed temperature.
This is very deep arguments I've never
appreciated fully when I was learning the
subject,
et Cetera.
Saws sick like definition because you
may not know that the temperature is
changing because this is the mometer
by postulate it's going to be the
temperature by definition. How can it
be wrong? What's wrong is that it's not,
we know it's not a reliable method
because physical phenomenon,
like when your rice, we'll cook. I'd not
reproduced by the boiling point of water.
It cooks in the plains
doesn't Cook in the mountain,
so we know the boiling point
is to blame the rice, the rice,
that's all we know that
that's not a good measure.
So nowadays people are much fancier
measures and I will tell you a little bit
about that, but for a long time
this was a very good start.
Don't worry about the fact that water
boils at differently in different
altitudes. You could go to sea level
and that's a good enough to definitions.
Sea level is pretty much constant all
over the world and you can see the
pressure that sea level is
the pressure at sea level,
just the road g eight of the atmosphere.
Okay,
so that's the usual
definition of temperature.
Now the trouble started
when people realize that if
you make a thermometer with
your favorite fluid,
maybe mercury and I make one with alcohol,
they will agree at zero and they will
agree with a hundred because that's how
you fixed it.
You read it so zero everyone says zero
hundred everyone says hundred but how
bout 74 degrees or 75 degrees?
I saved 75 if my fluid has claimed three
fourths of the way to the top at that
point, yours may not have claimed three
fourth of the way. In other words,
you've got two things, two graphs
with a zero and a hundred agree.
One graph may be like this one made me
like that so that when I think it is 75
you may think of 72 or 100 people agree
because we are cooked it up that way.
In other words, it's not true that
all liquids expand at the same rate,
so you will have to then pick one liquid
and say we were by that liquid and when
that liquid is gone halfway,
we would say it's 50 degrees,
so you'll have to pick a liquid,
you will have to have an
international convention.
You know that's the alcohol
lobby and those don't know
alcohol lobby. They argue.
Finally they found out a much
better solution than these liquids.
They found out that if you use a gas,
you can define temporary reducing
gases which have some very,
very nice properties and this is the gas
thermometer that I'm going to tell you
now. So he had a sub. You'd
build the gas thermometer.
Okay.
You take some gas in their container.
The typical container for me and all,
whenever I draw anything, thermodynamics,
it's going to be gas inside some cylinder,
which then waits on him
and that defines a
pressure that the guests,
of course the pressure will be the mg
of these weights divided the area of the
cylinder. That's the pressure
plus atmospheric pressure
and the volume is this, whatever
the volume is, base times height.
Here's what we asked you to do.
Take the product of pressure at times
volume for any sample of guests.
Take some gas,
put it in this tank and now put it on
different surfaces like a hot plate like a
stove like Pablo water and measured the
temperature using some standard methods
up to that point,
like a mercury thermometer.
What you'll notice is that the temperature
measured by some reasonable scheme
show us that the product that p
times B lies on a straight line.
If you connect the dots,
you find the product.
PV is linear in this temperature variable
and this is zero degrees
and this is hundred degrees.
No.
Here's the beauty of the gas thermometer.
If you take a different gas and you put
different amount of different gas in a
different cylinder, you want to get
some other graph may look like this.
What do you that does the run?
That's a hundred but most important
thing is that's also a straight line.
That's also a straight line.
It is the following application.
You guys can prove out your own leisure,
which is that if I think that my gas has
claimed 56% of the way of this height
to the top for the temporary,
that is 56 degrees. I ask,
what's your gas done? You'll find his
answer [inaudible] to 6% of the way.
It's a property of straight lines.
You can show that if it took two
straight lines, whatever, be the slope.
If they agree, if this is zero, this is
a hundred it's got a different slope.
When you have claimed
for the halfway point,
draw a line at 50 degrees and
ask what does any gas done.
They will all have claim to the
halfway point from the 0.2 100 point.
In other words,
gas thermometers will not only agree
at the end points where they must buy
construction.
They seem to agree all the way in between,
but that is one requirement.
This gas has to be very dilute.
Okay?
More diluted is the better it comes up
to take neon or freon at whatever you
like.
Don't pump it up with a lot of gas.
Put the least amount of gas you can
get away with. Then you find all gases
have the property that if you
calibrate them a zero and a hundred,
they agree in between that clear to you.
Take the product p Times v off your gas
by putting it on different surfaces.
Measure the product, plot
this graph, um, been able to,
whenever you're on ice,
you call it zero.
Whenever they run a boiling water, you
call it a hundred, you find the join,
they're connected by a straight line.
Then every point in between you've
divided equally leads to equal increase in
the product p Times v.
So Pre Times v for the gas is better
than the volume of mail courier volume of
water because it doesn't
depend on the gas.
So everybody can use the gas thermometer.
That's why we prefer the gas thermometer.
This is the interesting issue about a
measurement or definitions and sick league
definitions. You gotta be
careful. The last submitted,
I love you to pick anything you like
that varies with temperature and use that
as a definition of
temperature as a thermometer.
So why have some thermometers
preferred over the others?
The preferred over the others.
If the laws of nature take the simplest
form when described in terms of those
thermometers, in other
words, stick a meter stick.
What makes a good meter
stick photo standard?
You say the one that doesn't expand but
we don't know what that means because
that means the stick is the
standard by definition is right,
but in then you will soon find out.
That's not really that simple because
there are good and bad meters sticks,
but example the same meter
stick at one time of the year,
doesn't matter his own length
at a different time of the year.
Then we know that it's not a
good meter sticks. Similarly,
there are good and bad thermometers and
people at Avon, the gas, that moment,
this way
if you have a gas that more metered,
something very interesting came out of it.
Gas at one.
If you cool it below zero.
Okay,
and you asked which way is it going?
I don't know how low you could go.
In the old days,
people couldn't go far below zero,
but nowadays we can go to 1 billion
of a degree above a certain point.
I tell you now,
uh,
these thermometers indicates somehow
the product PB vanishes at a temperature
which is minus two 73.16.
Yeah.
So I just think that that is something
very special about that temperature
because if you took another gas,
well I'm going to do a little cheating
here that also extrapolate that same
temperature.
So all gases,
all aghast anemometers
say that is something very
special about this temperature
because that's when our
pressures all vanish.
So as you cool if given amount of gas,
even at a given volume,
if you keep the volume constant
and ask what pressure do I need,
how many weights to have to put on
that decreases and vanishes at this
temperature?
And this is called the
absolute zero of temperature.
Yeah,
it's called absolute
zero for many reasons.
One is that unlike zero of the Centigrade,
which is by no means the absolute
lowest possible temperature,
the absolute zero is the lowest
possible temperature. Why?
Because the gas pressure can be
reduced and reduced and reduced,
but the worst that can happen,
it can go to zero. That's it.
You cannot go below having no pressure.
We'll find in other ways.
Also,
this is the temperature at which you will
see conceptually no for the cooling as
possible. That'll record you don't
understand what hot and cold mean,
but right now this is all guests.
Anemometers pointed this temperature,
so people decided, you know what calling
this the zero is kind of artificial.
That's based on human obsession,
that water.
But if you think the loss of
scientists claim the whole universe,
what about planets where there's no water,
right?
You cannot describe, suppose you're
talking to at different civilizations,
planet of the Apes. You
want to tell those guys, uh,
we're going to set up a temperatures.
Zero is when water freezes and they say,
what is this thing called water?
You know the stuff you drink? Well,
you don't know what these apes are
drinking. Maybe they're drinking,
meeting or hydrogen gas,
liquid hydrogen, we don't know.
On the other hand, you say, uh,
take any vapor and wait till the product
of the pressure and volume go to zero.
Let's call that the zero.
That's a universal standard is not
paid to something called water.
It was fine for a while but it is not
fine as a universal aspiration but the
diameters, so zero temperature
is going to be set from here.
Once they did that,
they call that zero.
They needed one other temperature and
they decided that if you're starting the
new temperature scale, you will put
the zero knock at the centigrade,
but this is now called Kelvin
and everything will
follow a straight line,
but to define the what one degree means,
you've got to define
one of the temperature.
That's how we defined a straight line.
That temperature would be called two 71
3.16 but at this point it's called the
triple point of water.
What's the triple point of water?
You know water and ice can coexist and
you know that water and steam can coexist
at a hundred degrees, but we're burying
the pressure and temperature and volume.
You can actually find a certain magical
point in which bought ice water and
steam can't coexist simultaneously.
It cannot pick between
those three options.
Ice Floating on water is when water is
not decided whether to be ice or to be
water.
That's a coexistence point of two things.
And when the water starts
boiling in your store,
that's been water and steam coexist.
But I'm saying that a certain conditions
of pressure and temperature and volume
so that water ice and will coexist.
No,
that is a unique situation.
You cannot get to that by any other means.
And that temperature we will call
plus two 73.16 in this absolute units.
So basically what you've done by going
to the absolute units as your shifted the
zero to more natural point
where all grabs meat,
then you define the one degree Kelvin to
be so that to 73.16 that Kelvin brings
you to the triple point of water.
So if you find that confusing,
I'm just saying the boiling point
of water is not a fixed number.
You go to the mountains to changes,
but only under one condition can
water and ice and steam coexist.
That cannot be,
you cannot get that any other way.
So everybody will agree on that particular
situation and that will be called to
73.16 Kelvin.
Now that is a rule.
Apparently you can say degrees centigrade.
You're not supposed to say degree Kelvin.
That's a big deal made and a lot of
books I keep forgetting and said,
in fact I forgot again and nothing
terrible has happened to me.
So I don't think you should pay too
much attention to whether you can call
something degree Kelvin or simply Kelvin.
I think purpose of language is to have
no ambiguity's but when I say degree
Kelvin and I find that you
guys don't get confused,
I don't think that's a big deal.
What you'll find if you're
a very erudite person,
you will never write degree killed.
But having said that,
don't hold me to those standards.
I just don't feel any affiliation to
this particular completely are artificial
and empty convention.
But you have supposed to remember
if you take the GRE or something,
it's not called degree Kelvin.
Okay, so as far as we're concerned,
the Kelvin scale,
it's like the Centigrade scale
except the zero has shifted to here.
That's it.
That's the temperature scale you will use.
That's the absolute temperature.
Whenever I write t from now on,
I'm talking about Calvin,
not centigrade.
Now that's all about heat.
I mean all about temperature.
Now I'm going to talk about heat.
So heat is denoted by the symbol
queue and you got to ask yourself,
what are we talking about when
we talk about heat, again,
let's use your intuitive sense
of what heat is. You say,
I have a bucket of water, I want to
heat it up, and how do you do that?
You put the bucket on top of something
else which you'd think is harder,
and when the two are brought together,
somehow the water begins
to feel harder than harbor.
So we say we've heated the water
and we say we are transferred heat.
Now people were not sure what
really was being transferred.
What is it that's going from
the store to the water? Why?
Why is it that the stove,
if it's not plugged in is getting
cooler and the water is getting hotter?
They just decided to call
it the calorie fluid.
Yeah.
They imagined that it a certain fluid
which is abundant in hot things and not so
at and cold things.
When you put hot and cold together,
this magical fluid flows from hot to
cold and in the process heaps up the
quality
and they decided to measure it in
calories and so you have to define what
accountability is.
In other words,
you want to ask how much heat does
it take to heat this bucket of water
and the rules they made up was we
are going to define something called
accountability where the
number of calories you need
is equal to the mass of water,
times the change in temperature
and that's going to be
counted. These other words,
if I had a container with 10 grams
of water and the temperature went up,
I'm sorry,
this is mass of water in grams.
Okay.
At one gram of water and you did something
to it and the temperature went up by
seven degrees. You will have by
definition pumped in seven calories.
If this was a kilogram of water,
listen to be called a kilo candidate,
so sometimes I use grams and calories.
Sometimes you use kilograms
and kilo calories,
but the definitions are consistent.
If you put a kilo in the grand,
put a kilo in the calories.
Okay.
Now suppose you say,
I don't want to just talk about water.
I want to talk what he thinks.
Something else.
Maybe I want to hit the grandmas copper,
so then you write down the following
rule. Yeah, morning to heat.
It takes the heat up.
Anything pick your own
favorite material goal.
Then the amount of heat I think we can
all appreciate must be proportional to
the amount of stuff you're trying to heat
up. That's somewhat intuitive notion.
If you've got one chunk of gold
that takes some number of calories,
do you have a second, second
identical chunk? By definition,
that should take the same number
of calories you put them together.
It is clear that whatever
this calorie fluid is,
you need double that so it's got to
be a proportional to the mass of the
substance and has gotten a
proportional to what you're aiming for.
Namely an increase in temperature,
but this is true for any substance whether
they are eating copper or wood gold,
no matter what you're heating
it is through the heat.
Nita is proportional to
mass and at the temperature,
so what is it that distinguishes
one material from another?
We put a number here and that number is
called the specific heat speciphic feet.
This is a property off that material.
You got to understand certain formulas
will depend on certain parameters in a
genetic way and some things that
depend on the actual material.
In fact that a similar quantity, I mean
maybe I'll take a second to tell you.
If you go to the liquids that I said we're
expanding, you can do the same thing.
Take a rod and started eating it
and ask how much will it expand
if I,
he did buy some on belt the tea.
Okay.
What will it be proportional to?
Can anybody think of what it
may be proportional to? Yes.
Depends on the original length
of the right and the why is that?
Why do we think it's got to be
proportional to the length of the Rod?
Yeah, it's based on
what it had before. Yes.
Hold on.
That's correct. I think the way you,
one way to say that is take a meter,
stick it expand for some amount,
put another meter, stick next to it.
That expense pay the same
amount by definition of
identical things that for the
two meters stick,
we'll expand by twice as much.
So we put the length of that.
So don't matter to what you're heating
a block of wood block of Steve.
This is true,
but then the fact that he has different
effects on copper versus wood is the
pain is indicated by
putting a number here.
That Alpha is called the
coefficient of linear expansion.
And that depends on the material. These
are true no matter what you are heating.
So these specific numbers,
these coefficients,
these alphas that come in are
going to come and all the time.
So you should get used to that.
He has another one.
Let's play this game one more time.
We can ask how much is the volume of a
body changed when I heat it or the chain
of the volume again,
would it be proportional to starting
volume times the increase in temperature.
Then you put another number that's called
the Coefficient of volume expansion
and that depends on the material.
So if you take copper,
copper will have a certain alphabet I end,
we'll have a different alpha would.
We'll have a different outfit it material.
We'll have a different alpha.
This is the property of the
material. If you say, well,
I had something and when I heated it up
by one degree, increase by nine inches,
another one increased by two inches.
Is it clear that the first
one expands more readily?
It's not because the first one could
have been a my long second one.
Could I be in a foot long?
So you have to pick out certain factors
that are universal and the rest of it
you put into a property of the material.
Okay.
Similarly, many companies, specific heat,
you ask how much he does it take to eat.
Some object. It depends on the mass.
It doesn't matter what your heating.
Depends on increase in temperature because
that's the purpose of adding heat's
always going to be linear.
In the Delta t this one is a property
of the material and by definition see
equal do one calories per gram or the
one kilo calorie per kilogram for water.
Once you've got to remember
one calorie per gram for water,
you said definition.
Once you define water to have a specific,
either one calorie per gram,
you can define specific kid for other
materials by the following process.
So what do you do? You take a
container, put some water in it.
Let's assume the container, a zero
mass. I don't have to worry about it.
It's an approximation. If you're
worried about that, you know,
take a huge container so that the volume
of water dominates the surface area of
the container anyway. Containers
neglected. You got some water.
This water is served some
initial temperature t one
and I have some new material lead
and I want to find its specific heat.
So I take the lead in the form of pellets
and they hit the lead pellets with
some temperature deep too,
and I dropped these guys into this water.
That'll be an example where
initially the led is an equilibrium.
Maybe on a furnace,
a temperature,
tea to water is an equilibrium maybe
in the room, uh, temperature t one.
Then I put the pellets into the water.
There'll be period when the
temperature is not defined.
Then soon they'll settle down for
some common temperature called tea.
We will now postulate this
is a postulate are a lot.
The total change in Q is zero.
In other words, if Q is lost by one
body and gained by another body,
the loss and the gain was equal.
It's the new law.
You can make up all the new laws you want.
You don't have the right,
but this is the law you first make.
In that case,
what can you say in this particular
problem, in any of these heat problems,
I urge you to draw.
The following picture is one temperature.
Here's another temperature.
Here's the final one which we don't know
what we can measure with a thermometer
and measure it.
Then you say the mass of the water.
Then specifically the water,
which is one time Delta t which is the
final temperature minus the initial
temperature
data for the led pellet master.
The led that is going to
symbol PB time specific heat,
which I don't know.
Times change in temperature,
which is the final minus
d two is equal to zero.
The summer fall,
the MC Delta t zero.
Wow.
This is the gain of heat of the water.
This if you work it out,
we'll be a negative number because you
can see [inaudible] is below initial t.
This will turn out to be negative and
the positive and negative will add up to
zero. So what does it
you don't know? Well,
you know the mass of the
water specifically to
water is one by definition.
The final anti want to measure it,
but thermometers,
mass of letters for you to measure.
These are known. You can find c,
so this is a birthday present for you
guys. If you ever see this in an exam,
jump on this first because you've
been doing this in high school.
I know kids love this kind
of calorimeter problems. Yes,
I'm looking at the volume and expands
linear labor wasn't the problem with the
liquid bettering liquid volume.
Yes,
that's correct.
So the real point is if
everything expanded linearly,
we won't have the disagreement between
between different thermometers.
So it turns out to an
excellent approximation.
The channel length is
proportional to the length,
but it's not exactly proportional to that
will be terms involving higher power.
So like not only that specific either
materials is also not a constant.
We say specifically the waters one, it
turns out at a certain temperature range,
it will be one at a different
range. In fact, it's not quite one.
I totally long back.
Everything I tell you is wrong.
It's the question is how many decimal
places do you have to go to before you
honored my fallacies? Personally,
keep materials is not a constant.
It's a big industry.
Calculating the specific heat of
materials starting from atoms and quantum
mechanics.
So none of the things treated
as constants that ever constant,
including two alphas and Betas.
I can always find it by saying Alpha
itself may depend on the temperature and
also the dependence on element.
I'd be linear,
but you should also look at dimensional
considerations and say if it's not l if
you want to put an l square in the as
a correction to the formula to mass the
units, the l squared has to be divided
by another length to keep the units.
What are the links do we have? It may
turn out to be the intro comic spacing.
So once the atomic
properties come into play,
then you can find ways
to calculate corrections.
So all these laws are in fact
very tentative approximate.
These are pretty ancient physics. I think
the way I do the physics course here,
sometimes I'm the 1600 sometimes in the
1400 sometimes in the year 2000 so it's
going back and forth. This is way back
when people did not even know about atoms.
So they would try to do the best they can.
And what you found in empirically is that
once you find a specific heat for lead,
right,
you solve for it,
then you can do another experiment
using that value and you finally use the
right values. Delta Q does add up to
zero. Again, when you say adds up to zero,
accept a zero to very good approximation
during that park. Now that he parked,
when people do more than what I could
run experiments, everything has shot up.
In fact,
specific kids of art materials seem to
go to zero and yet when he approached
absolute temperature,
you have to understand the laws of
quantum physics to know why that happens.
Yeah,
so this is the period when people
are probing temperature ranges,
which are our own room temperature
are boiling and freezing point water,
which is a very narrow
window and temperature.
We look at the history of the universe.
You've got incredibly high temperatures
near the Big Bang and even now the rest
of the is bait at some temperature.
That happens to be very, very low,
which is near three degrees.
It's called the black body
radiation from the big bang.
So the temperature of the universe goes
through huge ranges and only when you
probe different ranges you see different
physics. If you come to Sloan lab,
you can go to temperatures were below
one degree Kelvin or hundreds of Calvin
and we heard a talk last year
physics that 1 billion of a Calvin.
Do you want to cool them and cool
Devon cooldown zero degrees Kelvin.
See that I go zero.
Kelvin is a barrier.
We're not able to cross just like the
velocity of light is something we are not
able to cross.
You said our big surprises,
the fact that velocity has an upper limit,
not obvious even to Newton. Why not?
Why not put rockets and Papa rockets?
Likewise when I build better
than better refrigerators,
the reason you cannot go below
zero is when you go to zero.
All the mechanical attributes
like pressure simply
vanish and they cannot have
negative values.
You will see more about this when you
understand he in greater depth anyway.
Right now Delta Q equals
zero is the rule you use.
I'm sure you guys know how
to do these problems. No,
that is a little twist that comes in.
I just want to mention that to you.
The twist is the following, so
I take some ice ice. By the way,
it's not always at zero.
You know you can go below zero,
your refrigerators several degrees
below a several tens below zero.
So let's take ice and let me measure.
I take this container, I put some
ice, I'd say minus 30 degrees.
I've gone to San Degrade now so we can
relate to ice and I put it on some source
of heat and I watch how
many calories are coming in.
Let me add in the device that'll pump in
a fixed number of calories every second.
So that's a function of
time. I'm expecting the
temperature of this to go up.
Do you understand that in every second
I get some number of calories and those
number of calories that are going
to produce for me and see Delta p,
m and C and constants. So Delta Q
is proportionally developed a t.
If you divide both by the time elapsed
and the rate at which the temperature
rises will be the rated with the heat
flows into the system if see it displaying
at a steady rate, temperature
should rise and indeed it does.
Temperature of the ice goes from minus
30 to minus 20 to minus 10 and so on.
But once it hits zero,
it gets stuck.
I know heat that's coming in,
but it's not getting harder.
But I notice that the
ice is beginning to melt.
That will be a period between here
and here. When I pump in calories,
I don't get any increase in temperature,
but I get conversion of ice into water
and that'd be a PD.
And when this guy,
I looked like some water with
some chunks of ice floating on it,
and until all the ice
is converted to water,
the whole system is stuck
at that temperature.
That's a very interesting property.
You know,
if you really took a real pot
and you put a chunk of ice on it,
you know what will happen, right?
The bottom of the ice will melt.
It may even evaporate.
That's not what I'm talking,
but because that's not a system where
there's a globally defined temperature.
I want you to hit the ISO slowly. The
minute you put a little bit of calories,
give it enough time for all these guys
to share that heat so that the whole
system has one single common temperature
and let's watch the temperature rise.
I'm saying it gets stuck at zero, but
your calories are getting you something.
They're converting ice into
water. Then you can ask, okay,
what penalty do I have to pay?
That's called the latent
heat of melting and again,
I know only in calories per gram.
It's 80 calories per gram for waters.
Some of your Delta Q now goes
not to raise the temperature.
What do melt? Some amount of stuff, uh,
at the latent heat of melting,
that's so much.
Q you need to melt that.
I'm on the stuff and the El
varies from substance a substance,
but water is 80 calories per gram.
If you want to melt mercury from
solid medicare, the liquid mercury,
it'll have a different number.
Then once everybody has become water,
then that uniform system of
water and started growing
and this is called a phase change.
Face changes when it changes its atomic
arrangement from a regular airwaves,
for example, the forms a solid
into a liquid in a solid,
everybody has this place,
you can shake it around where you are,
but liquid you can run around
the specific heat of eyes is not the
same as the specific heat of water,
so you've got to be careful. Even though
it's still made up of water molecules,
the calories needed to
hit one grammar wise,
roughly half of what it takes
to heat one gram of water.
So in these problems don't
make the mistake. Okay.
Then you go along and I guess you
know what the next stopping point is.
When you come to 100 degrees again,
it gets stuck,
delay everybody flip prices
and then you get steam.
Then you can have super heated steam,
which is even higher
than a hundred degrees,
so that's the latent heat of vaporization.
I really don't want even
want to write something.
I think it's 500 and something
calories for the brand.
That's information I
don't carry in my head
so you can,
if I tell you I took some ice at minus
30 and I dumped in 5,000 calories,
where will it end up?
You've got the first spend a few
calories going from here to here.
You've got some more money left.
You can start melting this.
Maybe you'll run out of stuff there.
Then that's what you will have some
amount of water and some are more device.
You got even more
calories at your disposal.
You can melt it all and start heating it.
You may come this way and you may
be running out of calories if not,
keep going here and there and there.
You may end up there if you've got enough
calories or one can ask a question,
how many calories does it take to convert
ice at minus 30 to say water and a
hundred we'll will have to hit.
You'll have to do the MC Delta t for
that m times the latent heat for this Mc
Delta t for that and m times latent
heat of vaporization for that.
So the kind of problems you can get
are fairly simple most of the time.
Yeah.
Only kind of problem where you can
really get in trouble is the following.
I will mention that to you.
Suppose I take some water and some ice.
So this is zero.
The Isis,
I'd say minus 40 water.
This at plus eight in fact,
let me make that also at plus 40
I bring them together and
ask you what will happen.
No, this is the subtle
problem. If, if you had to,
if he had water that party and he had
water the 20 you can easily guessed that
it'll end up somewhere in between.
You can calculate that was more subtle.
You've got water at 40 you've got ice
at minus 40 you bring them together and
ask what happens? Well, the answer will
depend on how much of this stuff you have.
If by water at 40 you mean
the Atlantic Ocean and bay.
I assume in a couple of ice cubes,
we know what's going to happen.
These guys are going to get clobbered.
They're going to melt.
You will end up somewhere here.
Then you can easily calculate the
final temperature by saying mc time,
this Delta t for water in magnitude
is going to be the he'd given to this.
He'd given to this as the MC Delta t
to come here than the heat to melt some
more device than the heat to raise
this amount of water to that final
temperature. Then you can solve
for the final temperature.
So if you want to solve this problem
and I give you some mass for this ice of
water and I give you
some mass for the ice,
you can first make the optimistic
assumption that you will end as water,
but at an unknown temperature, we
call it unknown temperature. T.
This is the t one.
This is the t to write your equations
except you like one more term there.
That's the heater takes to
melt the ice you solve for t.
If you get a positive answer,
you can use it because he's assumption
that you ended up on water meant you hit
it up.
The ISU melted the ice in the water,
then he hit it up the water
from zero to the final water.
But if it did the calculation
got a negative value of t.
That answer cannot be blindly used
because the assumption that you're on the
other side of ice is wrong. Then
you can try something else. Uh,
you can assume you're down here.
If you think you're down here,
then you'll simply heated
the ice from here to here.
This water you're brought down to
zero sucked out MC Delta t from that,
then you've taken out now
the latent heat of melting.
You take out heat when you freeze and
then you'd take an even more to come down
here.
Then all those losses of the original
water is equal to the gain of the size.
You can assume it here, you can solve
for this STI when you solve for this tea.
If you've got a negative number, then
you're okay. That will be good assumption.
If I say I sprinkled two drops
of water on a big iceberg,
we know it's going to end up his eyes
and that's a good starting point.
But if I give you a numbers
which are kind of wishy washy,
but I don't know whether this
will win or that will win,
that is the third possibility.
The third possibility is at the end
of the day you ended up here with some
amount of water and some of
them are device at zero degrees,
so that's a third option. You may have
to consider if neither of them works,
then the question is not what
is the final temperature,
but what's the question then what
do you want to know in that case,
how much his eyes and how much is water?
That's the question
and there are several ways to figure
that out. Let me just say in words,
I don't want to do this Algebra because
for you guys should be fairly easy.
If it's the question of suppose
both of the things I try fail.
I took a positive t as soon as I'm up
here and I assume the ice melted and they
get a negative answer that shot down.
You take a negative t and assume
everybody froze and that doesn't work.
Then I'm down to this option which is
some amount of water and some are more
device and the question
is how much is left?
You solved that by doing the following.
You say all this eyes
went from here to there.
It does that by absorbing that MC,
Delta t you know,
massive VI's and specifically
device times delta t,
maybe it was minus 40
the Delta t is plus 40
you give that heat to this guy
that hit you suck out of this guy.
When you suck that out of this guy
first you'll bring this to zero.
Then you still have some more
heat you can extract from.
You will use that to convert water into
ice at the price of 80 calories per
gram.
Maybe you can freeze five grams
or five kilograms of water.
That'd be the extra eyes lest we be.
Whatever water you started with,
the total mass will be the same.
But if you've got 60 grams of water,
you bring the 60 grams to zero and you
still have some more heat to be extracted.
Maybe you'll convert 10 grams to
ice and 50 will remain is water.
So the final answer will
be 50 grams of water,
10 grams of ice plus whatever
grams of ice you started with.
That's what the most complex
heat exchange problem.
If you guys want me to tell you some
more, I will add. I can, we'll want,
I don't know what your you on this.
Do you understand what you have to do?
Any it's problem.
Okay,
so it's the conservation
of a heat that's applied.
So the most tricky part is phase change.
When you got to face change,
you got to remember that the Formula Mc,
Delta t delta Q has one more
term that one more turn is this.
Okay.
So next question we ask is
what's the mandate in which
he managed this to flow?
We say you've got this calories man.
How does it flow? What the rate is,
what makes it flow?
So it turns out that are the
popular ways where he transferred.
One is called radiation.
Yeah,
radiation.
This,
when the heat energy leaves some hot
body and comes to you without the benefit
of any medium like heat from the sun,
so that's really
electromagnetic radiation.
That comes from heart glowing objects
and that actually comes to you and
electromagnetic radiation doesn't need
air, doesn't need anything. In fact,
if it needed it,
we will not get any heat from the
sun because there is no medium,
which means the earth and the sun.
Most of it just back here.
If you'd pick one of these space heaters,
no,
with glowing red cars and you feel warm.
If I pump start pumping the or bedroom,
of course you will be dying very rapidly,
but your last thoughts will be,
I am still warm because the
radiation will keep coming to you.
Okay. That's radiation heat that
are lots of laws for radiation.
I don't want to give them to you because
there are formulas memorized. Memorize.
Do. You don't understand too much of the
physics right now other than to say it's
electromagnetic radiation, whatever that
means. We haven't gotten to that yet.
That's what comes from there to here.
It can come and back.
Vacuum doesn't need a medium is the key.
Then the second way of heat
transfer is called convection.
So convection is explained by this
following example. You got water,
you put it on a hot plate.
Then in the lower part of it,
the water gets hot.
When it gets hot,
it expands and when it expands,
the density goes down.
Therefore by boy lasa buoyancy,
it will start raising up.
Remember I chunk of
water belongs in water.
I chunk of something else who lower
density will float to the top,
but the point is water doesn't have
a fixed density. If you heat it up,
the density goes down. So the water
guys downstairs have a lower density.
They're like a piece of cork. They will
rise to the top. When the rise to the top,
the cold water with the
higher density will fall down,
so you will set a bit color
hot races to the drop in.
Coal comes down and this also happens
in the atmosphere. On a hot day,
the ad next to the ground gets really
heated up and it rises in the call.
That comes down and they
set up this thermal cards.
So here you're trying to equalize the
temperature between a region which is
called in the region, which is heart
by the actual motion off some material.
In radiation you don't have the medium
transferring heat because the medium is
not even present in radiation. In
convection, the medium actually moves.
The hot guys physically moved to the
other players in the coal guys come here
and by that process the
heat is transferred.
Heat transfer I want us to focus on
is a little more quantitatively is
conduction.
So heat conduction is something
you've all experienced.
I mean if you have a skillet, why does
it have a wooden handle? Simple reason.
If you had a steel handle,
okay,
you
put it on the hot stove
and you put your hand here,
the fact that your body is at whatever
98 degrees and this one has gotten us 200
degrees, you're going to have
heat flow from here to here.
So we want to understand what's the
rated with heat flows from hot end of the
colon. So you can imagine that
rod of some cross section,
a one end of the ride isn't
some reservoirs at some
temperature t one other than
there's a temperature t too.
By the way,
I'm not introducing a new
term called reservoir.
Reservoir is another body like you and me,
except it's not like you and me.
It's enormous. It is so big that
it's temperature cannot be changed.
You can sit on it,
you will fry and you'll evaporate,
but it's temperature will not change.
Nobody's really a reservoir.
If you drop an ice cube in the Atlantic,
you lower the temperature of the
Atlantic but were negligible amount.
So take the limit of Atlantic, goes to
infinity, then you have a reservoir.
So reservoirs have one label,
namely what? Cyber temperature.
So something big enough can be,
this room is like a reservoir.
You put a cup of coffee, you say
it, it'll come to room temperature.
Actually they don't temporaries
that meets the coffee,
not halfway but slightly up.
Right.
But the room is large enough so that we
can attribute to the room temperature,
quite independent of bodies
that go in and out of it.
So this is connected on the left during
the anonymous tank of maybe a water ice
mixture at zero degrees. This is a
water steam mixture, maybe 100 degrees.
You put a rod there.
We know he is going to flow from the
heart body from the heartland of the cold
end and we wanted write a formula
for how much heat flows per second.
Again, I'm going to write these
formulas over and over again.
You got to ask yourself
what will it depend on?
What are the properties
it'll depend on in general,
independent of what the rod is
made of. Can you think of one? Yes.
You said the cross section of where
did we say what reason can you give for
cross?
Yes,
yes.
Okay. Let me repeat this argument. You
take one ride, I put convenience listed.
Just take it to be a rectangular rod.
Take another Rod, rectangular Rod.
They will both transfer the same amount
of heat for a given amount of time.
Just glue them together and say,
here is my new rod.
We know it's going to transmit
twice the amount of heat,
so it's going to be proportional.
The area and why is the heat flowing?
It's flowing because of a temperature
difference, so that's always there.
That's the underlying
force for heat transfer.
That's the dynamics in thermodynamics.
That's what makes the heat flow,
but then we find as an empirical fact
that if these two reservoirs were
separated by that distance,
then the heat flow is a lot
less than when they are closer.
It seems to depend on how much temperature
differences packed in spatially,
so you want to divide by Delta
x is not infinite decimal.
It's the length of the rod separating
the heart and cold hands. In other words,
if you dilute the temperature
difference over one mile,
the heat flow will be
correspondingly reduced.
Whereas the pursuit temperature
difference between a very small spatial
separation, that'd be very robust flow
of heat. That's what we were saying.
This happened to be true.
You realize independent of what material
I'm talking about when I said one rod
was one rod is arts. It doesn't
matter what it's made of. Again,
having put all these factors,
which you can argue on general grounds,
you have to now ask
what happens when this,
the copper rod versus silver
rod versus wouldn't drive.
So you've got to put one more number,
which is capped by here,
not care you guys kappa
and it's called the uh,
the thermal conductivity of that material.
Sometimes you put a minus sign,
a minus sign just means
it flows from hot to cold.
I don't care whether you put the plus
sign or don't put the minus sign.
Anybody knows that the heat is
going to flow from hot to cold.
So just remember that, that action
of flow and that's all I had a board,
the sign here, this cap buys
the property of the material.
Once again, let me tell
you, you can say, well, uh,
I had two reservoirs, hot and cold. I
connected them with two different rods.
This rod carry twice the amount of heat,
but a second I see other rock
isn't necessarily better conductor.
No,
maybe it had 10,000 times across section.
So what do you want to do is to make the
playing field level and compare rots at
the same cross section. Same
temperature difference, same length.
Then ask who conducts more heat.
That depends on the material and that's
the thing you pulled out specific to the
material that is a
property of water, copper,
steel as the heat conductivity.
Okay.
Now final topic.
Is this going to be more of a hand waving?
Now I don't want to get
into too many details.
It really has to do
with the water is heat.
The old days people just said it's a
fluid and they postulated the conservation
law for the fluid.
You can postulate what you want.
You got to make sure that it works and
it seems to work in the sense that all
the delta cues in any
reaction add up to zero,
but then people were getting hints that
maybe this thing that we call heat is
not entirely independent of
other things we have learned.
So where do you get the clue? One clue
is long back when we studied mechanics,
we talk about two cars. They come and
collide. They slam into one big lump.
Now you've got no kinetic energy,
no potential energy.
Potential energy is always zero.
They're moving on the same height.
Kinetic energy was one half MBA squared
for this one, half MV squared for that.
At the end there's nothing, no kinetic,
no potential. We just gave up and said,
look, conservation of energy
doesn't apply to this problem.
We just say it's in the lasting.
On the other hand,
we find whenever that happens
we find the bodies become hot.
Here's another thing you can do.
It can take a cannon ball,
drop it from a big tower, the south.
Some people in the French army,
I think first detected this feature.
You drop cannon balls from a big height.
When they hit the sand,
they start heating up or you drill a hole
in the canon that what counts somebody
did,
and you also notice that
you need to constantly pour
water to keep the drill bit
from heating up.
You find very often mechanical
energy is lost and things heat up,
so you get a suspicion,
whatever the underlying mechanism,
maybe that is a rule that says if you
lose so much mechanical energy that you
cannot account for, then it translates
into a fixed number of calories.
If that is the case,
then we'll at least get a dictionary
on between calories and Jules.
So Jules is energy.
You can see calories as energy.
You cannot see that was
going to be the premise.
But first you've got to prove that every
time you lose some number of jewels,
you get a fixed amount of calories
and that experiment is do the jewel,
is a jewel experiment. It's very, very
simple and tells you the whole story.
You have a little container
in with that is a pattern.
This is a shop with a pulley.
And then so wait here.
So I try to imagine this guys,
you got rope wrapped around the top pulley
and when you let this weight go down,
you're going to go down like this.
It's going to spend the shop.
I put some water in here and I have
some friends that are sticking out,
so the return up the water,
so it's like this thing,
the egg beater, right? In fact, I try to
do the experiment with the egg beater,
the summer to a bunch of high school
kids and I got totally humiliated because
nothing happened as planned,
okay? But the idea is the same.
You agitate the water in some fashion,
but this guy did it in
a particular simple way.
My egg bidding was not good enough.
You'll see them maybe in a while.
Why that's not good.
What he did was to put these parents,
let the weight go down from there to here.
Now we can keep track of how much
mechanical energy is lost, right?
Because of this mass was
addressed and it dropped the hide.
AMG dropped high date.
It's supposed to have MGH can energy.
Let's say it's got some kinetic energy,
which is not equal.
The MGH MGH minus kinetic
energy is missing.
Some number of jewels are gone.
The water gets hot.
When the water gets hot,
you can immediately ask how many
calories was supplied the water,
because that water,
it heats up the same way.
Whether or not you put it on a hot
plate or whether or not you churn.
It doesn't seem to depend on how it
got hard. This has the same effect.
This is water is hard in every real sense.
So you must have put some calories so you
can find out how many calories you put
in by looking at the
master water specifically,
the water is one looking at
the increase in temperature.
So some jewels are missing, some
calories have been pumped into the water.
The new ask is of a proportionality
between jewels and the calories.
And you find that is,
and that happens to be four
points to Jewel's for a candidate.
In other words, if you can expand
4.2 joules of mechanical energy,
you got yourself one calorie to be
used for whatever heating purposes.
So in the example of the collide in cars,
this had some energy that has some energy,
all measured in juggles the
slam together they come to rest.
That means you can take
those many jingles,
divide by 4.2 and get
some number of calories.
Imagine the whole car
is made out of copper.
Then those calories will produce
an increase in temperature,
right equal to Delta Q is Mc,
Delta t.
That will be the rising
temperature of the car. In fact,
there'll be other losses because
you heard the sound well,
that's some energy gone. You won't get
it back. Maybe it sparks are flying.
That light energy that's gone.
If it's a project all that out,
you find that in the end the calories
explain the missing jewels so that made
people think
that this is just another form of energy
because if you add this
to your energy balance,
there is no reason to go on apologizing
for the law of conservation of energy.
Law of conservation of energy is not
in fact violated even at the inelastic
collisions.
If you include heat as a form of energy
and the conversion factor is 4.2 joules
per calorie, but the question is,
what right do you have to call it?
Energy.
We think primarily when he says
somebody is energetic, give me that.
Someone's running around my
endlessly back and forth.
Entities associated with motion.
These two cars were moving and where
every right to say they have energy.
How about potential energy will live.
This star card starts climbing
up the hill and slows down.
We think it's got potential.
You let it go.
It'll come back and give you the kinetic
energy. So most people's idea of energy,
just candidate energy that is lost
and yet you get calories in return.
So you ask yourself, what can it be?
Well,
the correct answer to that came only when
we understood that everything is made
up of atoms. Once you grant that,
everything is made up of Adams.
Then it turns out that kinetic
energy of Adams is what we call heat,
but it can be very careful.
Take a tank full of gas.
I throw it at you. That whole tank is
moving. That's not what I call heat.
Okay.
That motion,
you can see I'm talking about a tank
of gas that doesn't seem to be going
anywhere yet.
It got motional energy because the
little guys are going back and forth.
So what we will find this,
what I'm going to show you next time is
that if you kept track of the kinetic
energy of every single
molecule in this car,
every single molecule in that car
before and after, and you added them up,
you will get exactly the same number.
The only difference will be originally
the car has got global common velocity,
macroscopic velocity.
You can see on top of it,
it's random motion of the molecules that
make up the car. So does the other car,
when they slam together,
the macroscopic motion is completely gone
and all the motion is thermal motion,
but it's still Kennedy, Kennedy. And
that's what we will see the next time.